Please change it to. Let's change the
characters to are you the. I'm gonna do it.
Please be fierce. Please explain.
Hyrule Fade.
This is when the link of the kingdom is a vertical art. In the
Grace of the World, it was an adventure of link alone, but this time
it is said that he is cooperating with the Hyrule Kingdom and other races to see the monsters.
The monsters at the gate where Ayuchin is entering could be implemented with a cannon, so it
seems that all the rain jelly fans who are going to create even better Haruma stuff from
now on are in the situation where they can make money by submitting other
things.  As for the equipment, I haven't been able to meet him, so
it's quite likely that he's obese.
[Music]
Abe Character Action Eh
Hyrule Each character has its
own character action.  The Impressed
Breath throne is also happy in India
Yes, that's right,
it means to do it. It's a good idea to say bowing a and now.
Good,
this work is old and the link is getting older, but it
's gradually unmatched.
Various options
Because it's the world before this year,
it's a story about that Hyrule white day
before.
There is a part that
you can enter, but there is a place like that square for food.
Well, if that is just the beginning of the battle, it will
be a strong yes-type ceiling.
I will also show you
[Music]
The battle of the project that was involved in correcting the height of the floor is
the art of the weak point gauge that is currently displayed.
It
seems that there are more and more first-come-first-served months,
unfortunately it was not just fighting from the front but
with a function.
No
The exhilaration around here is still so
yes
As for the operation, it seems that such people can play with the policy of Zelda Musou so much.The feeling of the
base is also the feeling of Zelda Musou or Musou
.
As the light grows stronger, you
can control the base if the economy is
booming. I think you can avoid it
.
It was
in the way that it was stopped at t. It wasn't successful at all in the wave. It was
successful now at the perfect timing, and now it's blue, so it's said that it was suppressed.
I
heard that
I'm heading to the next base.
When I'm milking in a file on my back, it's not an
item or a new one, and I won't eat
more at the next place.
That's right, this is the highest 100 years ago, and I
wonder if the world of Grace would take it with the
link alone?
It
means that you have suppressed one of those missions,
right? Well, there is a map in the lower right, so this area where you are going to capture it is
not all the two layers so far.  Please have an excessive system
.
[Music]
What's the matter? Yes, I want to open
what I want to do.
I was worried about it. It's like a
guardian-like child stick in the white
. Someone who went there is a place. The
hawk's eyes are a little more. The usual grace of the bell is a
tall feeling, but it
grows very much.  It made a
sound like I was doing, but
I said that I would route the actual machine for a while. That's
right. For some reason, c Gliding isn't going to tell you.
Of course,
you can enter 2 anymore.
Let's do this as an action that can realize exchanges and connect with aerial attacks.
And more and more people with aging are coming.
Yes, it's a
character action and c.  I'm translating the
strong enemy I mentioned earlier,
but I think that the icon is just right.
I said like this.
We were accelerating the strong enemy like this. We threw the square and the round alternately and did our best. It was
all-you-can-eat. It
's a ring 100 years ago.
It seems that bgm also has a great arrangement, isn't it?
It's the best of the world sound arrangement and
chai-like fun with all the naked teams who
also have bgm.  It's a child, it's a
familiar bomb, it's a
high-seeker item, it's a high-seeker item, and it's prosperous because it's like fighting by using these options
and using the environment
.  That's right, it
was
spring when
I couldn't do this, and I feel like I'd like
to compare it for a while.
There was a chance, wasn't it? It was a
little far away.
I thought that
Saki Aso, who seems to be attacking with that pulse seal, was able to succeed with one shot.
Rush attack corps
Please propose and be a maker.
Furthermore, if you control the point gauge immediately from there
, it seems that it is a form that the cows are chased together.
It's far away, isn't it? It's the one with the finger part
. When
I try to climb to work, Arao appears. It's okay
.
I
had a cool image that I thought was so cute  Deiko-san,
2 tanks, 2 tanks,
100 years later, it appeared to guide that link,
but I'm investigating as a referee 100 years ago
.  In
the case of stolen goods, if you
eat it as a member, the
number of singer will increase and you are
worried about it.  There is heavy snow per wool grain
and there is black that you can get sex.
Absorbing a little member will increase your alter ego.
5 The number of defeats will increase and you will have a chance to shave at 0 o'clock.
It's been a long time since I've collected and used it in the
environment.
9 It's not good.
Then, is it around here for this battle?
1 You'll want to see it for a moment
.
Nyan
[Applause]